president trump planning to sign an
executive order at this afternoon's
vaccine summit that would prioritize
americans access to the coveted vaccines
before the u.s helps out other countries
all this coming just two days
before a panel of fda advisers will meet
to discuss
emergency vaccine approval joining us
now white house
vaccines are dr monsef salawi welcome
back doctor great to have you here this
morning so as far as this
executive order that is intended to
ensure
that americans get access to the vaccine
ahead of
other foreign nations what is the goal
with this and what are we expected to
see from the white house on that front
today
well listen what the white house is
doing is what the white house is doing
we at the operation are working very
hard on making sure that we have
as many vaccine doses from as many
vaccines
as possible from our portfolio available
to the american people
we have committed to have enough vaccine
doses to immunize the full population by
the middle of the year
2021. we remain confident this will be
the case
we are also remembering that on may 15
the president
has said that once the american people
will be vaccinated
uh you know supplemental vaccine doses
available to us
could be made available to the world i
assume that
whatever may be announced this afternoon
will be in line with that
but in the meantime we're focused on
making these doses available for the
american people
okay so we had admiral jurar on
yesterday
um and we were talking about how do we
get back to normal life because at the
end of the day we all see the light at
the end of the tunnel when we're talking
about the vaccine doctor
he had suggested that we need to see
about 70 to 80 percent of the american
people
having had this vaccine both doses of it
before we can actually see a return to
that normal life we all once had
listen to this
by the time we immunize 50 or 60 million
people
we can have all the long-term care
facility a lot of the at-risk people so
we'll get a lot of the benefit
but we will not end the pandemic in
other words really
end the disease transmission until we
have at least
about 70 or 80 percent of the american
people
who have either been immunized or have
gotten the the
the virus being so intimately
part of this vaccine roll out doctor
is that possible are we going to have
enough of the vaccine
to cover 70 80 percent of the population
yes that's absolutely possible that's
our plans and we feel very
confident that we will be delivering on
them probably by the time 70 to 80
percent of people
are immunized we will be somewhere in
the month of may
i think at this moment the highest
concern i have
is the level of hesitancy within the
population
as to accepting whether they will be
immunized or not we're working very hard
to make sure all the data about these
vaccines performance the safety and
efficacy
will be transparently discussed through
the fda
process with the verpack which is the
advisory
independent experts advising the fda
and then more experts will have access
to that data and i hope
will be able to relay to the population
independently how effective these
vaccines are
i'd like to also say that we have these
two vaccines the pfizer vaccine and the
moderna vaccine
that will be reviewed in the next few
days and week but we there's two more
coming that are completing their phase
three trials that are likely to read out
in early january
and become available we hope in february
to further increase the number of doses
we have
that's why we feel confident that we
will be able to immunize the u.s
population
as a whole dr slawy how do how do you
address that public fear
um as as the doctor heading up war warp
speed and making sure that this vaccine
is available
that is an enormous task that you have
undertaken
did you did you think about the public
fear sorry side of this i mean you you
walk down the street and you ask people
would you
will you get it if it's available at
your local doctor's office it's shocking
to hear
and see some of these studies that say
about 50 percent of people say
they don't want to be first in line to
them you say what
well it's very concerning and i say a
few things first
try to explain why we went fast we went
fast
not by cutting any corner we took
advantage of technological advances that
happened over the last 10 years
we took financial risk and operational
risks we did larger trials than
than what's needed those are the things
that allowed us to go very fast
number one number two we will make all
data available
and explain it and have independent
experts look into it and explain it to
the population
hopefully people have different experts
that they may
that they may trust i ask people to just
keep your mind open please don't come to
a conclusion
before you have been exposed to the data
and then the third thing
i say is just a personal example i have
an eight years old kid
as soon as this vaccine will become
available for children it's not yet now
i will make sure he has it i will take
the vaccine as soon as it is approved
if i'm authorized to do so and
you know those are the level of
confidence i have the people i love
most on the earth i'll make sure they
get the vaccine because i know
the data and i know it's safe and
effective
okay dr slow it was really something to
see that uk woman 90 years old
sat down and took the first dose of that
vaccine this morning we hope
um that that that happened soon here
doctor thank you for your time this
morning appreciate it
thank you thank you for having me